merci beaucoup monsieur le mini nous
sommes extrêmement
heureux de vous accueillir parce que
votre champ de compétence et pour nous
un objet d'intérêt majeur et de
préoccupations à force et je dirais dans
ce contexte au-delà du défaut
d'attractivité ou du manque ou de la
baisse plutôt d'attractivité de la
fonction publique territoriale nous
constatons aussi ce phénomène que
j'appelle de
désenchantement des mers et qui ne
relève pas simplement on va dire du
phénomène de violence mais aussi de la
difficulté
d'accomplir administrativement les
fonctions qui sont les leurs et qui
demande beaucoup d'expertise et qui
nécessite d'être accompagnés par du
personnel que je tiens à saluer parce
que nous savons alors on dit souvent
que les mères sont
les hussards de la République une sorte
d'Ar des ombres extrêmement positifs
mais que ces maires et de manière
générale les exécutifs des collectivités
seraient juste empêchées d'agir s'il n'y
avait alors côté leurs bras armés que
sont les fonctionnaires territoriaux qui
ont un sens de l'intérêt général et du
service public qu'il convient vraiment
de souligner au Sénat nous ne manquons
pas de le faire mais chacun d'entre nous
ayant une expérience
locale souvent d'exécutif nous savons ce
que nous devons
à nos fonctionnaires et ce que le
service public doit et ce que nous
habitons doivent et on l'a vu dans des
périodes
compliquées comme des périodes de crise
covid ou encore je pense aux périodes de
grandes chaleurs rappelez-vous nous
avons dû suivre un par un
nos habitants nos personnes âgées
pendant la canicule et si les élus sont
des inventeurs de possibles moi je pense
vraiment que les fonctionnaires sont les
producteurs de c'est possible et parfois
c'est plus compliqué de produire que que
d'imaginer alors on a un profond
changement vous le direz mieux que nous
et mes collègues aussi sur lorsqu'on
appelle le rapport au travail le rapport
à l'emploi que celle en tout cas on
avait en France une fonction publique
territoriale très stable les gens
s'engagaient dans la fonction publique
et il partait en retraite après avoir
accompli parfois le même métier dans la
même collectivité tout ça ça a bien
changé il s'agit pas d'avoir des regrets
nostalgiques mais en tout cas de dire
qu'il y a nécessité de prendre en compte
tous ces tous ces besoins toutes ces
attentes et tout ces changements et je
ne pense pas qu'il s'agisse uniquement
forcément de régime indemnitaires de
reconn salariale certes nécessaires mais
il y a sans doute bien d'autres choses
autour de la qualité de vie au travail
la prévention l'aménagement du temps de
travail donc votre prédécesseur avec
comment on est un rapport sur
l'attractivité de la fonction publique
territoriale qui avait été rendu par
Philippe Laurent il y avait notamment
une recommandation qui était sur le
développement de la marque service
public nous avons eu l'occasion
d'auditionner quelques exemples
pardonnez-moi de faire valoir ma couleur
locale et ma bretonitude comme disait
certains mais nous avons auditionné
notamment cette marque d'aide BZ
d'autres portent Catherine lifolco et
d'autres nous en parlerons mais voilà
qu'en pensez-vous comment voyez-vous les
choses et comment pouvons-nous avancer
alors je veux saluer le travail
porté initié par les collègues dont
Catherine difolco qui est au Sénat
là on va dire une experte du
du statut de la fonction publique
territoriale je veux saluer Jérôme du
Rhin qui est aussi très engagé sur le
sujet que complet à mon travail je sais
que Jérôme a une contrainte ouais on
maîtrise pas les trains et Cédric via le
même ce trio au travail aujourd'hui sur
l'attractivité de la fonction
territoriale avec un volet particulier
sur les secrétaires de mairie et vous
savez l'attachement que nous portons ce
sujet puisque au Sénat une de nos
collègues qui d'ailleurs membre de la
délégation aux collectivités et son
groupe ont porté une PPL dont nous avons
discuté dont nous aurons peut-être
l'occasion de reparler prochainement je
ne serai pas plus longue je vous
souhaite la parole
sachant que le couvre-feu est vers 12h
monsieur
ça vous va puis moi je laisse la parole
ensuite à mes trois collègues merci
beaucoup monsieur et bien merci madame
la Présidente et Mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs et sénateurs je vois d'abord
vous remercier de cette invitation
prévue de longue date pour cette
audition vous remercie pour vos propos
entre l'outils de la présidence qui je
crois font parfaitement le lien avec les
enjeux qui sont les enjeux de nos élus
locaux et vous faites une corrélation
qui me semble assez juste entre parfois
les difficultés une forme de
désenchantement et les enjeux RH
l'action des élus le cours repose sur
celle des fonctionnaires territoriaux et
je crois que l'enjeu d'attractivité que
vous avez placé au cœur de votre travaux
et effectivement aujourd'hui peut-être
devenu la priorité numéro 1 sur nos
territoires je le dis et vous me
permettrez de d'avoir une pensée émue et
une forme de propos solennelle pour
saluer l'engagement des agents du
service public dans une semaine qui a vu
certains membres de drames et qui nous
rappellent que cet engagement là mais
les agents publics en première ligne et
en première ligne des violences qui sont
celles de notre de notre société
merci donc d'engager ces travaux et je
proposerai dans les cette dizaine de
minutes de propos liminaires pour au
fond lancer nos échanges de tirer
quelques constats et de dresser les
chantiers qui sont engagés qui sont les
chantiers que j'ai engagés avec les
employeurs publics avec les employeurs
territoriaux singulièrement pour
répondre à cet enjeu de l'attractivité
au développement de la marque employeur
de la fonction publique territoriale
peut-être d'abord dresser quelques
constats demande souvent où sont les
difficultés en matière de recrutement
sur quel type de sur quel type de métier
la réponse la plus pragmatique c'est que
c'est un peu partout en réalité c'est
vrai je dirais pour les agents de
catégorie C c'est vrai pour les agents
qui sont en première ligne je pense au
métier de la petite enfance au métier du
soin au métier du lien et toutes les
collectivités remontent des difficultés
de recrutement c'est vrai aussi pour des
filières en particulier peut-être plus
transversale je pense à des métiers qui
sont en tension de façon inhérente sur
le marché du je pense à la filière du
numérique par exemple et vous savez les
difficultés de recruter un certain
nombre de compétences mais c'est aussi
vrai de filière sur des métiers supports
dont on parle un peu moins souvent parce
qu'elles sont peut-être plus
transversales encore je pense à des
filières administratives je pense à nos
attacher et les collectivités
connaissent des difficultés de
recrutement y compris sur ces filières
là alors si nous en sommes au constat
peut-être
quelles sont les causes de ces
difficultés d'abord je crois qu'une
société qui va vers le plein emploi
créer des difficultés pour tous les
employeurs privés comme public je le dis
d'un mot mais ça vaut le coup de se le
dire quand même parce que parfois on se
flagelle d'une certaine façon en tant
qu'employeur public des difficultés de
recrutement l'ensemble des employeurs
connaissent des difficultés de
recrutement aujourd'hui je pense aussi à
un autre fait générateur qui est moins
souvent mentionné dans le débat public
qui est un enjeu de démographie on part
jamais de démographie quand on parle de
nos difficultés de recrutement la
réalité des faits c'est que bon nombre
de fonctionnaires qui ont été recrutés
autant ou à laisser le port était
ministre de la Fonction publique sont en
train de partir à la retraite maintenant
et qu'on a une base de départ à la
retraite et les secrétaires numériques
ils nous ont occupé qui continueront nos
occuper sont je crois une bonne
illustration d'une filière avec des
enjeux de démographiques qui sont
importants il y a des difficultés
d'attractivité qui sont intrinsèques à
la fonction publique on y reviendra et
et et plus particulièrement sur des
zones des territoires qui ont des
difficultés particulières de zone de vie
chers de territoires en tension avec des
difficultés d'accès au logement qui font
je crois partie des constats que nous
pouvons tirer et donc une fois que j'ai
posé un grand trait c'est quelques
constats quels sont au fond pour moi les
chantiers qui nous font engager il y en
a certains qui concernent les enjeux de
fiches de paie et de dynamique de
rémunération il faut avoir la lucidité
sur ces questions là
ne pas les regarder en face serait je
crois passer à côté d'une grosse partie
du sujet à un moment répondrai ou
maintenant plus d'un tiers des
fonctionnaires de la territorial sont au
niveau de rémunération du SMIC et c'est
un enjeu auquel on doit pouvoir apporter
des réponses le deuxième sujet c'est
toutes les sujets qui sont tout autour
la fiche de paie que vous avez mentionné
vous aussi madame la Présidente sur les
conditions de travail et qui répondent
aussi à des transformations du rapport
au travail moi je suis pas du tout
convaincu par la thèse de la grande
démission en revanche il y a bien une
grande transformation par rapport au
travail et nous devons en tant
qu'employeur répondre et relever un
certain nombre de promesses employeurs
pour relever le défi de l'attractivité
et puis il y a peut-être sera le
troisième axe de mes propos introductifs
un enjeu de mobilisation pour mieux
faire connaître les métiers de la
fonction publique territoriale et cette
clé d'entrée autour des métiers je crois
que c'est le fil parce qu'il tire le fil
des compétences et les plus fortes
révolutions qui sont devant nous c'est
justement la gestion le développement
des compétences et nous devons être
beaucoup plus capables de raisonner
la clé d'entrée métier et la clé
d'entrée compétence que parfois par des
étiquettes collées sur le front en des
fonctionnaires territoriaux ou des
agents publics de façon générale qui
sont parfois un tout petit peu
difficiles à décoller donc pour moi ce
sont les trois axes de travail je tresse
ici quelques perspectives et peut-être
pour ouvrir nos échanges et ne pas être
trop long sur les enjeux de carrière et
de rémunération pour moi il y a trois
enjeux le premier c'est d'abord comment
on accède à la fonction publique toutes
les modalités qui sont parfois
extrêmement différenciées en fonction
des statuts d'emploi en fonction parfois
des versants la fonction publique et ce
sont des enjeux auxquels on doit pouvoir
répondre aujourd'hui parce que ils ont
parfois des biais ils créent des effets
de concurrence entre employeurs sur un
même bassin de vie quand je prends un
exemple vous avez parfois le CHU d'un
bassin de vie fonction publique
hospitalière qui est capable de recruter
des agents sur titre et dans la filière
médico-sociale dans une structure
municipale donc fonction publique
territoriale on impose pour les mêmes
postes les mêmes compétences à
recrutement au concours et donc parfois
vous avez un CHU qui vient piquer les
agents permettez-moi de cette expression
et vice versa vous avez tous en tête des
exemples donc on a un travail à monnaie
de mise à plat au fond des conditions de
recrutement ça veut pas dire supprimer
le concours parfois et vous verrez qu'il
y a un fil rouge qui est plutôt de
défense du statut dans ces origines et
ses fondamentaux mais je crois qu'on
doit être capable parfois de
professionnaliser certains concours de
le recentrer sur les questions de
compétences un maire me disait le jour
je peux pas me passer de quelqu'un qui a
15 ans d'expérience dans la petite
enfance parce qu'il fait trois fautes
dans la dictée voilà je pense que c'est
au fond peut-être le meilleur résumé de
cet enjeu de professionnelisation des
concours parfois de mise à plat de nos
capacités de recrutement sur titre et
sur certains faits en particulier je
pense à la question de l'apprentissage
qui fera peut-être l'objet de de
certains échanges on doit pouvoir être
capable de faire de ces voilà et ça fait
une forme de petites révolution
culturelle en développant
l'apprentissage dans la fonction
publique 30 000 apprentis l'année
dernière dans la fonction publique une
vraie voix de pré recrutement et je
porte le projet de pouvoir faire en
sorte que à la fin d'un contrat
d'apprentissage s'il y a une volonté
partagée de l'employeur et de l'apprenti
d'être titularisé qu'on puisse tituler
sur titre sans passer par un concours
dès lors qui est à 18 mois un minimum
d'un contrat d'apprentissage donc il y a
un enjeu sur l'accès il y a un enjeu sur
les parcours de carrière et là je vais
pas être trop long on aura l'occasion
d'en échanger mais je crois que la
question des compétences et donc des
enjeux de formation et de développement
de compétences ou de reconnaissance de
validation des acquis de l'expérience
doit être davantage mise au centre c'est
d'essuyer sur lequel on n'est pas
suffisamment bon dans la fonction
publique la VAE de la fonction publique
ça n'existe pas suffisamment et donc on
doit être cette plus capable de
reconnaître le développement de
compétences soit par l'expérience soit
par la formation pour donner des
possibilités d'évolution plus rapide et
je le dis d'un mot pense que moi je suis
pas du tout un détracteur du statut
parfois on me dit au fond vous avez
l'intention de supprimer les catégories
ABC prenez des conventions collectives
de plein de secteurs professionnels il y
a aussi différentes catégories le point
de difficultés qu'on a dans la fonction
publique c'est que parfois quand on est
recruté catégorie C par exemple c'est
difficile de franchir le plafond de
verre d'une certaine façon à un moment
donné de son parcours professionnel et
donc moi ce que je souhaite développer
plus tôt c'est pas de supprimer les
catégories c'est de permettre des
franchissements plus fluides à la main
et quand je pense à la fonction publique
territoriale en faisant des réformes
qu'on pourrait apporter plutôt à un choc
de marge de manœuvre pour les employeurs
territoriaux pour permettre plus de
fluidité je pense en disant ça par
exemple à la question évidente des
rigidités autour des quotas de promotion
qui était un temps adapté en termes de
recrutement extérieur par rapport aux
promotions internes mais qui je crois
nécessite un assouplissement et c'est
l'engagement que j'ai pris auprès des
employeurs territoriaux et puis ce que
je me vois déjà être un peu trop long je
mentionne rapidement des enjeux de
rémunération pour dire mais on pourra
évidemment en échanger qu'il y a des
enjeux de court terme on vit une
deuxième année à 6% d'inflation au
globale mais plus encore concentré sur
l'inflation alimentaire sur les produits
qui viennent en particulier toucher des
bagues grilles et donc on a un enjeu de
court terme et je le dis dans une
semaine de concertation avec les
organisations syndicales qui ont repris
au sein de mon ministère et donc on
devra apporter des réponses à ces
questions de pouvoir d'achat et on devra
mener un travail plus structurel sur la
manière dont on rémunère les
fonctionnaires les agents publics
contractuels ou fonctionnaires pour moi
autour de trois principes que je cite
rapidement un principe de protection et
d'oxygénation des grilles pour répondre
à l'enjeu d'écrasement des grilles un
fonctionnaire qui démarre sa carrière
aujourd'hui catégorisée mais douze
années avant de voir une évolution
indiciaire c'est très difficile de
construire un discours d'attractivité
sur ce fait là et donc c'est pour un
principe important qui doit aller de
pair avec un principe de dynamisation et
d'évolution des carrières je suis très
marqué par cela les agents publics me
disent au fond j'ai un enjeu à un
instant T de combien je suis payé en bas
à droite de ma fiche de paye mais le
sujet c'est aussi je vois ma collègue à
15 ans de plus que moi qui gagne 150
euros de plus par mois est-ce que je
suis prêt à faire ces 15 années qui me
séparent d'une telle augmentation de
salaire en d'autres termes on doit
s'intéresser à la pente des courbes et
c'est peut-être un angle mort d'une
certaine façon dans nos politiques RH je
crois que c'est à ça qu'on doit pouvoir
répondre y compris parfois en assumant
une logique de différenciation des
évolutions de de carrière ça je ne sais
fait débat on a introduit un principe
d'accélérateur de carrière dans la
réforme de la haute fonction publique et
je crois que ce principe il doit pouvoir
innerver les réflexions qu'on doit avoir
sur l'ensemble des agents publics et
puis un troisième principe qui est la
récompense de l'engagement et de la
performance individuelle et collective
et c'est dans la bouche du ministre de
la Fonction publique pas un gros mot que
de parler de PER formance et je crois
qu'elle est compatible avec ce qu'est
notre statut aujourd'hui et puis je les
évoquerai très rapidement sur ces deux
chantiers le chantier que je citais
autour de tout ce qui est autour de la
fiche de paye on doit pouvoir apprendre
un certain nombre de transformation j'ai
ouvert un chantier
qui consiste à mettre davantage l'agent
au centre je crois ce principe de
symétrie des attentions si on va être
capable de rendre un service public aux
usagers on a ces dernières années essayé
de porter des progrès il y a encore
beaucoup de chemin à parcourir pour
placer l'usager au centre mais au fond
se donner les conditions de réussite
c'est placer davantage l'agent au centre
de nos réflexions autour de promesses
employeur j'en citerai six qui sont les
chantiers que j'ai pu engager en méthode
en associant systématiquement les
employeurs territoriaux dès le début ce
que je crois qu'il faut arrêter de
penser pour la fonction publique d'État
et ensuite décliné pour la fonction PICT
territoriale c'est dès le début je
donc voilà engagement pris de méthode
mais je crois que c'est ce que j'essaie
de mettre en oeuvre dans les groupes de
travail autour de ce chantier de
fonction publique plus autour de ces 6
promesses employeurs l'une autour du
management et il faut pouvoir parler
management et
enjeux managériaux sur les cadres
les cadres intermédiaires dans la
fonction publique ça veut dire formation
initiale et continue c'est beaucoup
d'enjeux autour des concours des écoles
du service public j'étais à lunettes il
y a quelques semaines ça veut dire
évaluation professionnelle et remise à
plat des enjeux autour de l'évaluation
professionnelle deuxième enjeu c'est la
simplification pour les agents eux-mêmes
c'est-à-dire tous ces irritants du
quotidien qui viennent complètement
parfois mettre à bas un discours d'être
activité quand quand vous avez une
mutation de poste on sait pas vous dire
combien vous allez être payé parce que
les si RH les systèmes d'information ne
suivent pas ça c'est des sujets où il
faut des améliorations continues sur ces
sujets là il y a un troisième enjeu aux
promesses employeur autour des
conditions de travail et je pense aux
thématiques de santé au travail de
prévention et notamment de prévention de
l'usure et de la pénibilité c'est un
sujet qui est intimement corrélé au
débat que nous avons eu sur les
retraites nous avons lancé à quelques
jours une mission confiée à des
inspections et à des personnalités
qualifiées et je au président des
centres nationaux de gestion des centres
de gestion de la fédération de gestion
Michel hiriard qui a accepté de plancher
sur ces questions là pour pouvoir mettre
en place ou développer davantage des
outils collectifs et mutualisés pour les
collectivités territoriales de
prévention de l'usure et de la
pénibilité je pense aux chantiers que
nous menons et aux discussions autour de
l'instauration d'une protection sociale
complémentaire dans son volet santé et
dans son volet prévoyance les
discussions sont très activement en
courant en ce moment elles pourront là
aussi nourrir nos échanges troisième
promesse employeur ou quatrième plutôt
l'environnement de travail
télétravail tant de travail
transformation des espaces de travail
sobriété énergétiques sur les lieux de
travail et je crois que cette thématique
elle marche ensemble et c'est comme ça
en tout cas je pense que ça peut être un
objet y compris de négociation au sens
des ordonnances potentiellement avec les
organisations syndicales que d'essayer
de dégager des lignes directrices sur
ces questions qui me semblent très
importantes cinquième et sixième
chantier l'égalité professeure et femme
et les hommes le Sénat a voté à à
l'unanimité moins deux abstentions une
avancée importante sur l'index ou
l'instauration d'un index d'égalité
professionnelle dans la fonction
publique et le renforcement des
ambitions autour de dispositif de
nomination équilibrée mais il faut aussi
travailler à l'éradication des violences
sexuelles il faut aussi travailler à
l'amélioration de l'environnement de
travail sur des thématiques importantes
de santé des femmes au travail donc ce
sont autant de chantiers qui sont
engagés et puis dernière élément le
logement des fonctionnaires qui est
absolument central et qui doit là aussi
faire l'objet de le plus approfondes et
je conclurai en disant que c'est tout ça
au fond qui doit être le fondement notre
campagne de communication autour de la
marque employeur et l'attractivité on
parle marc-employeur parfois en
réduisant ça un film ou à une campagne
d'affichage une certaine façon ça doit
pouvoir donner traduction à des éléments
de communication on le fait on a relancé
une campagne trois versants autour de la
marque choisir le service public.fr mais
qui est simplement un point de
cristallisation pour fédérer l'ensemble
des initiatives vous en avez mentionné
quelques unes bretonnes madame la
Présidente il y en a dans tous les
territoires qui doivent nous permettre
de mettre en synergie les différentes
mobilisations autour de la marque
employeur des plus de 300 métiers de la
fonction publique territoriale avec et
je conclut par ça une clé d'entrée qui
doit être celle des métiers moi j'en ai
un tout petit peu marre des campagnes
parfois autour de la fonction publique
ou on ne voit que des médias absolument
extraordinaires qui en réalité sont
réalisés par une ou personne je crois
que ce qui fait la fonction publique ce
sont les métiers du quotidien sont ceux
des agents territoriaux sont ceux de nos
policiers municipaux de nos secrétaires
de mairie et c'est l'ensemble de ces
métiers là qui font le caractère
extraordinaire de servir l'intérêt
général et de servir aujourd'hui le
service public donc moi je crois que il
y a pas de fatalité il faut regarder les
constats en face oui le nombre de
candidats au concours public a été
divisé par deux ces 10 dernières années
c'est un constat objectif mais c'est
aussi une occasion de bouger les lignes
et de bouger les lignes plus rapidement
qu'on aurait pu le faire peut-être il y
a quelques années et de nos difficultés
autour de la tractivité je crois que on
peut montrer que la fonction publique
change bouge et quelques jours j'ai
relancé
l'initiative de mener un salon autour de
l'emploi public trois versants national
il y a plus de 4000 personnes qui sont
rendus à salon ça veut dire que la
fonction publique continue d'intéresser
et donc voilà je déjà été trop long mais
ça lancera peut-être les échanges en
vous remerciant madame la Présidente si
beaucoup monsieur le ministre de
votre
colganiser chers amis
mes collègues sont forts galants et moi
j'apprécie ça merci
non mais on aime bien aussi la
galanterie c'est pas un gros mot merci
monsieur le ministre pour pour votre
propos introductif je relève avec
bonheur que vous souhaitez dorénavant
peut-être faire une différence entre la
fonction publique d'État et la fonction
publique territoriale et hospitalière je
suis ravie d'apprendre ça parce que
réellement quand pendant des années on
nous a dit voilà ça se passe comme ça à
l'état on va transposer dans la
République territoriale
un employeur à l'état 50
000 employeurs en public territorial
donc voilà il y a des différences
énormes et on peut pas tout transposer
donc merci si cette il y a une avancée
dans ce sens là
j'ai simplement pour
pour compléter vos propos sur les les
salaires
certes dans l'attractivité de la
fonction publique il n'y a pas que la
rémunération mais il y a quand même la
rémunération je pense que autrefois
quand on n'est pas forcément en pleine
emploi la fonction publique est une est
un refuge
c'est plus le cas maintenant clairement
et
si quelqu'un qui rentre dans le dans le
monde du travail à la possibilité
d'entrer dans la fonction publique ou
d'entrée dans le privé il va regarder
effectivement en bas à droite de la
feuille de salaire ce qui se passe et
clairement la différence est notable
juste pour compléter vos propos une
petite étude qui vient juste d'être
faite à propos de l'augmentation du SMIC
au 1er mai plus de 2,22% donc ça fait 38
euros brut
dans la fonction publique c'est un
nouveau tassement ça veut dire que les 8
premiers chelons de la catégorie C sont
maintenant au SMIC les 8 premiers Chelon
il faudra attendre 13 ans pour connaître
une revalorisation très en pour gagner
14 euros 55 non mais c'est juste pas
attractif vous êtes d'accord les trois
premiers de la catégorie B sont aussi au
niveau du SMIC même en catégorie B on a
la punition et alors on est selon au
premier échelon de la catégorie A il est
plus qu'à 130 euros brut du SMIC autant
dire pas grand chose et donc si le SMIC
évolue comme il commence à évoluer là
le premier restant de la catégorie A
sera au SMIC en 2025 2025 c'est demain
donc il y a vraiment un gros problème
quoi vraiment un très gros problème donc
voilà ensuite je voulais vous parler
peut-être rapidement de problèmes qui
existent entre
les différences entre le secteur public
et le secteur privé et je veux parler de
par exemple du handicap de la prise en
compte du handicap il est plus
intéressant d'être un travailleur
porteur de handicap dans le privé que
dans le public
parce que dans le privé vous pouvez
avoir une allocation qui compense votre
perte de
faculté à travailler dans le public non
il y a un moment on vous dit retraite
pour invalidité ou vous allez travailler
à temps partiel mais il y aura pas de
compensation et j'ai un cas je me
permettrai de vous le soumettre vraiment
ou c'est édifiant une jeune femme qui a
une maladie handicapante mais qui veut
travailler elle veut travailler elle
veut pas être à la retraite elle veut
travailler seulement elle ne peut pas
travailler à temps plein et elle n'a pas
de salaire à temps plein elle serait
dans le privé elle aura une compensation
donc il y a des petites choses comme ça
qu'il faut toiletter si on veut toujours
parler d'attractivité et de récompenser
les gens qui ont envie de travailler
pour le public avec le vrai sens du
travail public voilà monsieur le
ministre pour l'instant je laisse mes
collègues merci
ma présidence
de questions pour ma part
la fonction publique et des divers ça
fonctionne plus vite territoriale est
aussi et c'est un paysage qui est assez
morcelé on pourrait presque dire qu'il y
a deux divisions et les questions que
vous avez posées sur la promesse
employeur elles sont elles se posent pas
dans les mêmes termes quand on est dans
les collectivités d'une taille
importante où on a un environnement de
travail des collègues une un parcours
possible des facilités d'accès à un
certain nombre de sujets que vous avez
évoqués et dans des toutes petites
collectivités avec ces 19000 secrétaires
de mérite qui sont assez isolés où la
promesse employeur ne prendra pas la
même forme est-ce que vous avez pu
documenter un peu les difficultés
particulières liées à cette à ce cette
myriade de collectivité ou finalement
c'est souvent un agent voire deux et où
toutes ces promesses employeurs pourront
pas être traités dans les mêmes termes
deuxième de questions sur l'attractivité
globale de la fonction publique on est
dans un contexte dont vous avez rappelé
qu'il est marqué par une difficulté
partout qui est marqué aussi par des
transformations très profondes
sociétales sur l'aspiration au travail
ce qui fait l'intérêt du service public
de la fonction publique c'est le sens du
service public c'est le service de
l'intérêt général c'était aussi le
statut il y a le biguite il y a toutes
sortes de formule qui qualifient dans le
secteur privé comment on peut aussi
travailler sur l'image du service public
de la fonction publique dans ce contexte
où les aspirations des nouvelles
générations sont assez différentes
Cédric oui merci Madame présent de
Monsieur le Ministre moi deux petites
questions un peu général et puis après
je reviendrai sur des questions très
courtes j'en ai quatre sur la question
spécifique des critères d'abord sur
l'attractivité de la fonction publique
et je rebondis sur ce qu'on dit mais de
collègues il y a évidemment ce phénomène
de trapassaler là qui qui est un
problème majeur pour l'attractivité et
pour pas seulement pour être rectifié
mais même pour les agents en poste et
deuxièmement on change des changements
sociétaux dans la dans le rapport au
travail notamment chez les plus jeunes
générations il est plus rare maintenant
de voir des des jeunes travailler dans
nos collectivités refuser d'être
titularisés parce que justement le
statut qui avant était le Graal il y
avait un il y avait un deal quand on
entrait dans la fonction publique on
était moins payés mais on avait la
sécurité de l'emploi aujourd'hui chez
les jeunes générations dans cet
arbitrage entre la sécurité et la
liberté ils font le choix de la liberté
et
c'est plus le jeune on n'a plus peur de
de perdre son emploi on a on a peur d'y
rester malgré nous et donc ça pose je
pense des des questions de fond sur le
statut de la fonction publique la
manière d'y rentrer et la manière de
conserver les gens à l'intérieur et
cette arbitrage en tout ce que j'appelle
moi entre liberté et sécurité qu'il faut
peut-être revoir et vous l'avez un peu
ce qui s'est dans vos questions tout à
l'heure il se pose la question du
concours c'est c'est l'ADN de la
fonction publique l'entrée par concours
aujourd'hui
dans le privé on rentre en fonction des
diplômes ou de l'expérience les diplômes
ou l'expérience il est pas rare de voir
des bacs plus 5 qui soit catégorie C ou
catégorie B parce que ils ont passé ce
concours là et on a une adéquation du
coup entre ce que permet le concours et
et et la personne qu'on soit recrutée
donc en termes de politique RH ou de
management comme on disait tout à
l'heure c'est très compliqué en
s'appuyant sur les concours et vous
l'avez dit avec de votre mère on a
régulièrement aussi ce genre de phrase
quand une secrétaire de mairie par une
catégorie C veut passer B qu'elle passe
un concours on lui demande de faire une
note de synthèse etc sur des sujets un
peu généraux qui n'ont rien à voir avec
son expérience et son quotidien Nice
c'est comme si vous demandez un ouvrier
du BTP d'être de faire un examen de
couture pour pour pouvoir gagner un
échelon supplémentaire donc je pense
qu'il y a un sujet de Fond ici et on est
très curieux de vous entendre là-dessus
très rapidement quatre questions courtes
sur les la situation des secrétaire de
mairie
premièrement vous savez qu'il y a une
une revendication notamment de l'AMF de
créer un stand un statut d'emploi
particulier pour les pour les
secrétaires de mairie
donc sur le statut d'emploi particulier
sachant que le cadre d'emploi a été
supprimé notamment pour un certain
nombre de difficultés qu'ils pouvaient
poser qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
sachant que l'esprit d'Amérique ne
souhaite pas que
créer un emploi fonctionnel donc est-ce
que pour vous il est possible de créer
un statut d'emploi particulier qui ne
soit pas un emploi fonctionnel est-ce
que c'est possible ou pas première
question la deuxième c'est le rapport
entre les fonctions publiques on a
beaucoup de demandes ou les relations
avec les préfectures sont de plus en
plus enfin importantes et
forte et pourtant on a plus
d'interlocuteurs
ils disparaissent même des courriers
qu'on reçoit ou avant on avait le nom de
l'interlocuteur ou une adresse mail
maintenant on a on a la jonction sans
savoir vers qui se tourner donc
et est-ce que est-ce que vous seriez
favorable vous pensez qu'il serait
possible de pouvoir à l'instar un peu ce
qui s'est fait avec la DG fibre quand
ils ont supprimé les perceptions et que
le conseiller de conseiller local est-ce
qu'il serait envisageable d'avoir dans
chaque préfecture un référent pour les
scrutins du préfet ou autre qui
permettent de faire l'interlocuteur
unique avec les secrétaires de mairie
peut-être les maires
autre point concernant le la NBI la NBA
a été augmenté pour discrétaire de
mairie de 15 à 30 points jusqu'à 2000
habitants mais quid des critère de
mairie au-delà de 2000 habitants parce
que comme vous savez le décret me dit
que les stats américains exercent dans
les communes de moins de 3500 habitants
à partir de 2000 on peut être DGS si on
est catégorie A mais on n'a pas on n'est
pas forcément sur le poste de DGS
fonctionnel donc si on est catégorie à
mais qu'on n'a pas un poste fonctionnel
ou si on est catégorie B au-dessus de
1000 habitants on n'a pas le droit à la
NBI pourtant on exerce le est-ce que
vous pensez c'est quelque chose qui peut
être corrigé et troisième et dernière
question pardon c'est sur la
rémunération liée à la responsabilité
il y a la NBI qu'il y a la fonction il y
a le l'IFS qui peut être lié à l'agent à
ses qualités etc c'est motivation ou
autre par contre quand on a des des
secrétaires mis en catégorie C ou B
c'est c'est souvent des tâches
d'exécution or là elles ont une
responsabilité d'ailleurs il y a des
textes qui qui reconnaissent la
responsabilité des secrétaires de mairie
est-ce que vous pensez possible
souhaitable qu'on puisse créer à
l'instar ce qui existe pour les DGS une
prime de responsabilité qui qui
permettrait à l'employeur de de
revaloriser le l'agent quel que soit son
grade en fonction de la responsabilité
est-ce qu'il est en position
hiérarchique est-ce qu'elle gère des
équipements est-ce que et en fonction de
la responsabilité et non plus uniquement
de la fonction qu'on puisse instaurer
cela voilà je vous remercie
qu'on vous permet de répondre aux
questions de notre rapporteur et ensuite
on a une demande de parole d'Antoine
Lefèvre et de Silver Robert voilà
et Christine excuse-moi Christine en
fait il y a un écran qui qui cache la
moitié de la vue par nos je vous en prie
Monsieur le
voilà c'est bon merci madame la
Présidente merci à tous les trois pour
pour ces questions qui je crois son
coeur de au coeur des sujets madame la
sénatrice il faut que vous avez insisté
à votre tour sur l'écrasement des
grilles c'est évidemment je crois un des
sujets numéro 1 auquel il faut qu'on
puisse qu'on puisse répondre aujourd'hui
je conteste aucun des chiffres que vous
avez donné et ils sont parfaitement
parfaitement juste je vais même me
permettre de les compléter parce que
avant l'augmentation du point d'indice
l'année dernière quand on a pris cette
décision augmentation de 3,5% du point
d'analyse qui répondait à une inflation
qui était elle-même qui avait été quasi
gelé pendant longtemps avec des
parenthèses timides entre 2016 et 2017
on avait 700 000 agents la fonction
publique était au SMIC après
augmentation du point d'année si on
était tombé à zéro agent de la fonction
publique qui était rémunéré au niveau du
SMIC et on est en train avec la
dynamique autour du SMIC je la critique
pas la conteste pas c'est une forme de
protection pour les plus bas salaires
dans le pays mais on envoie aussi des
limites c'est parfois intéressant de
l'avoir en tête dans le débat public
qu'on a autour du SMIC puisque sur un
peu plus d'un an l'augmentation du SMIC
a été d'un peu plus de 10% en réalité et
nous avons peut-être des étapes qui sont
encore devant nous sur ces questions là
je vais prendre les formules de
réindexation du SMIC et donc on voit
bien les limites on a pris cette
décision au 1er mai qui correspondait à
la loi de faire en sorte qu'aucun agent
public soit évidemment comme ça peut
arriver dans certaines branches
professionnelles rémunérées en dessous
du niveau du SMIC on l'a fait d'ailleurs
je le dis au passage sous une forme qui
est celle de l'augmentation de l'indice
minimum de traitement c'est à dire dans
le dur par une augmentation indiciaire
là où l'usage avait parfois été de faire
des compléments indemnitaires et donc un
peu de bricolage sur ces questions là
donc moi j'assume d'avoir augmenté
l'indice minimum de traitement mais il
nous ramène ces questions là aujourd'hui
20% des agents de la fonction publique
au niveau de l'indice minimum de
traitement et par
composition plus forte de catégorie C
dans la territoriale 36% des agents de
théâtre au niveau du SMIC donc ça c'est
le premier sujet auquel on doit répondre
ça pose bien le débat des discussions
qu'on a avec les organisations
syndicales parfois aussi
l'avantage du point d'année c'est que ça
réoxygène des grilles je l'ai dit à
l'instant c'est limite c'est que ça fait
des augmentations indifférenciées quelle
que soit le niveau de rémunération dans
la fonction publique qu'on soit au
premier niveau ou qu'on soit la plus
haute rémunération au plus haut
fonctionnaire du pays avec un effet qui
en volume d'euro parfois un peu
inégalitaire ça que quand vous augmentez
en pourcentage évidemment la somme pour
les agents de Badri sera bien inférieur
à l'augmentation que vous accordez au
plus haut fonctionnaire du pays pour
lequel nous menons des réformes et
j'assume par ailleurs c'est un autre
débat d'harmoniser par le haut pour
trouver l'attractivité et attirer les
meilleurs talents mais donc on a là un
effort qui je crois doit être
particulièrement concentré sur ces
questions de ceux qui sont les plus
impactés par l'inflation forte je disais
l'inflation globale en train de se
tasser mais elle reste très fort sur les
produits de première nécessité donc elle
touche en particulier les plus bas
salaires et par la même on doit pouvoir
apporter des réponses à cette question
et ce besoin d'oxygénation des grilles
l'attractivité ça doit être aussi celle
de l'ensemble des agents publics et
notamment ceux qui sont en situation de
handicap vous l'avez mentionné les
lignes ont bougé sur cette question là
on a fait progresser le nombre d'agences
situations de handicap la fonction
publique territoriale et hospitalière
est plus en avance que celle de l'État
sur cette question là et donc faut
regarder là aussi les choses en face
avec un point sur lequel on est mauvais
je le dis en lucidité c'est
l'intégration d'apprenti en situation de
handicap là on est très en dessous des
6% et je pense qu'on a un axe de
progression qui devrait nous permettre
de passer au dessus des 6% de
travailleurs en situation de handicap
mais preneur de vos exemples
particuliers sur des cas où on perd au
fond à rester en activité et aussi sur
tous les enjeux d'adaptation des postes
on a aujourd'hui un fond le FIP HFP qui
existe qui permet de financer
d'adaptation des postes qui marchent
plutôt bien dans une logique de
résultats quand on a conventionné mais
tous les employeurs publics ne sont pas
encore en conventionnement avec le fpht
je crois que ça doit être un des axes
sur l'environnement de travail et
effectivement le lien avec le Centre de
Gestion et aujourd'hui fluide je veux
répondre ce sénateur du Rhin sur la
question de des deux divisions que vous
allez mentionné qui me semble là aussi
parfaitement juste avec je pense deux
sujets derrière qui sont posés c'est à
dire parfois des mécaniques y compris de
compétition entre collectivités parce
que il faut se dire les choses on a
assez d'un années beaucoup fait dans
l'indemnitaire beaucoup fait par la
différenciation catégorielle en fonction
de tel ou tel métier et pas beaucoup
fait de façon structurelle et de façon
indiciaire et donc on a laissé une forme
de champ de compétition se développer
entre les employeurs par des mécanismes
de différenciation recyloter et par la
même on empêche la mobilité entre entre
employeur parce que on voit bien que
basculer de l'un à l'autre ça va faire
basculer dans un champ indemnitaire que
parfois certains opéants ne sont pas
capables de suivre et donc c'est l'objet
qui est posé vous avez un geste-t-il de
poser qu'on a eu le débat par exemple
sur les secrétaire numérique dire bien
sûr on peut dire que les employeurs sous
utilisent parfois les outils qui sont à
leur disposition j'ai mentionné à
l'occasion du débat en séance une forme
de sous-utilisation des outils Recep
pour les secrétaires admirer mais vous
m'avez dit je crois à l'esthétique mais
prenez vos responsabilités aussi d'une
certaine façon je reviendrai aux
questions que c'est viable me poser pour
apporter des réponses en indiciaire et
ça fera partie des discussions qu'on
doit avoir de savoir si pour reprendre
des termes un peu technique on est
capable de faire un peu de convergence
prime point une certaine façon qui
nourrit aussi le débat sur les retraites
puisque la partie indiciaire cotise pour
les retraites ce qui est pas le cas pour
l'indemnitaire et qui doit être mis en
face d'une modulation des parcours de
carrière d'une dynamique la récompense
de l'engagement en tout cas moi c'est la
philosophie de travail que je peux avoir
et le deuxième sujet qui est posé par
votre question c'est celle de la
capacité de mutualisation des employeurs
aujourd'hui il y a un très fort
mortellement vous avez mentionné 50000
employeurs territoriaux parfois et les
spectateurs un bon exemple chacun sait
ici elles ont un deux trois quatre
employeurs parfois territorial des
outils de mutualisation existent c'est
parfois le cas et je crois que c'était
le débat que vous avez eu précédemment
au niveau des intercommunalités et on
aura l'occasion d'en discuter sur le
fait peut-être de mieux encadrer la
possibilité d'emploi par une
intercommunalité les textes existent sur
ces questions là et donc je pense qu'on
est plutôt dans le champ de
l'encadrement des pratiques et de la
mutualisation des bonnes pratiques ou
par les centres de gestion qui peuvent
jouer déjà un rôle mais peut-être qu'on
peut un peu mieux là aussi asseoir parce
que je crois que la mutualisation doit
quand même être une réponse aussi à ces
questions là
je reprends les points que Cédric Vial
mentionné je reviens pas sur les traces
à salaire parce que c'était un point qui
convergeait peut-être sur au fond quelle
est l'avantage qu'on est capable de
proposer avec le statut aujourd'hui à
quelqu'un qui regarde de l'extérieur la
fonction publique c'est vrai que
l'aspect stabilité de l'emploi et
parfois même j'ose le terme devenu
quasiment à repoussoir de dire au fond
j'ai l'impression de d'être pieds points
liés dans une carrière d'autant plus si
je suis obligé de faire le même métier
toute ma carrière je pense que les
professeurs sont des bons exemples de ça
c'est-à-dire un moment donné soit
j'aimerais rentrer dans ce métier là
plus tard dans ma carrière et je pense
qu'il faut concentrer les efforts sur
les jeunes mais pas que beaucoup de gens
sont aujourd'hui dans des
questionnements sur la reconversion
professionnelle ont vu le covid ont vu
l'intérêt aussi nos services publics se
pose des questions de sens mais parfois
sont rebutés par la faible capacité de
la fonction publique à prendre en compte
et à valoriser leurs années passées
professionnelles
et j'y pense pour certains profils qui
se posent la question de devenir prof
parfois et qui sont on va rebuter par ça
donc il faut qu'on soit meilleur et
qu'on améliore les lignes là-dessus j'en
fais un axe de travail et je crois qu'au
fond ce qui est devenu pour le coup un
avantage rémanent du statut c'est la
diversité des carrières qu'on est
capable de proposer moi j'ai des débats
parfois avec des syndicats je suis
transparent là sur le fait d'améliorer
la situation des contractuels on l'a
fait récemment par exemple pour
harmoniser les congés maternité les
agents contractuels avec les agents
titulaires j'assume je considère que ça
c'est de la mauvaise différenciation
c'est pas parce qu'on est contractuel
qu'on devrait être puni et moins bien
protégé qu'un agent titulait donc je
suis plutôt favorable à essayer
d'améliorer la situation des
contractuels je le dis au passage il y a
une mesure qui a été retoquée par le
Conseil constitutionnel dans le cadre du
projet de loi retraite qui était très
intéressant pour ça pour faire en sorte
que on prenne en compte les années
passées des contractuels titularisés
dans les catégories actives c'était pas
le cas aujourd'hui moi je savais pas
expliquer que un
aide-soignant qui est passé 6 ans en
contrat et qui ensuite est titularisé
donc on va on se donne les moyens de le
fidéliser c'est quand même tout l'enjeu
pour l'hôpital pardon de ce détour un
instant dehors de la territoriale mais
on sache pas lui dire que les 6 ans
qu'il a passé au contrat elles vont
compter dans sa durée de service pour la
catégorie donc je prends l'engagement
ici qu'on trouve le véhicule législatif
et cette mesure d'amélioration de la
situation des contractuels elle soit
appliquée dans la fonction publique je
pense qu'elle est nécessaire mais donc
moi je suis plutôt pour faire
éliminer les mauvaises différenciations
voilà et je trouve qu'il y en a trop
aujourd'hui vous faites le même métier
que vous soyez contractuel dans la
territorial au titulaire un fonction
publique des tas tout va être différent
pour vous et ça c'est pas normal pour
assumer la bonne différence et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la toux du statut c'est
en terme d'employeur et marque employeur
c'est le cœur de nos débats aujourd'hui
c'est pouvoir de dire on est capable de
vous proposer une diversité de carrière
comme Aude qu'un employeur dans le pays
n'est capable de vous proposer ça c'est
le message très fort par exemple d'un
salon et et de montrer la diversité des
métiers et dire quand vous êtes
contractuel vous êtes embauché pour une
fonction donnée c'est le deal et vous
pouvez pas en changer ou alors faut être
titularisé en revanche quand vous entrez
dans la fonction publique vous allez
pouvoir faire 50 métiers différents sans
changer l'employeur il y a pas un
employeur dans le pays qui est capable
de proposer ça et donc c'est cette
fluidité là pour redonner je crois de la
toux sur les concours j'en ai dit un mot
et vous m'invitez à au fond à
approfondir de en une minute mais
je crois qu'il y a deux axes
1 de pouvoir parfois se passer du
concours pour faire plus de recrutement
sur titre sur certains métiers et je
pense à des métiers où les compétences
terrains primes parfois même sur le
diplôme ou les compétences théoriques
et je crois que je serai un peu court si
je disais que c'est la seule solution et
je le dis justement pour un travail
assez approfondie avec le CNFPT et avec
des centres de gestion voir avec les
centres le Centre national de gestion
pour la fonction publique hospitalière
ils disent attention elle est pas trop
vite là-dessus il y a parfois il y a un
intérêt à garder un concours mais en
revanche de revisiter de toiletter le
concours pour professionnaliser nos
concours c'est à dire enlever ce qui est
inadéquat et aller plus au cœur des
compétences et là il peut y avoir un
intérêt donc je pense que c'est cette
double axe qu'il nous faut poursuivre je
veux mentionner que des groupes de
travail qu'on est en train de mener avec
les employeurs territoriaux on a pu
aboutir à des premières avancées je les
cite on a pu acter la suppression des
preuves d'administes d'admissibilité
pour tous les cadres d'emploi de la
filière médico-sociale dont les concours
ne comportent plus qu'un entretien avec
le jury
c'est intéressant on a également acté
avec les emporteurs territores la
suppression des concours pour les
assistantes territoriaux sociaux
éducatifs éducateur territoire de jeunes
enfants cadres territoire de santé
paramédicaux infirmier territoriant en
soins généraux on va poursuivre ce
travail-là il est issu d'un travail de
bon sens qui part du terrain et qui peut
être discuté mais je trouve que ça
avance dans la bonne la bonne direction
ça c'est sur la partie concours après
sur les secrétaires de mérite je termine
par là alors au fond ça sera le coeur du
débat qu'on je crois qu'on aura à
l'occasion de l'examen de la proposition
de de loi
moi je crois comme vous de ce que j'ai
entendu vos propos que recréer un emploi
fonctionnel ça serait pas la bonne idée
et ça serait peut-être une fragilisation
parfois des secrétaires de de mairie
revenir à la situation antérieure d'un
cadre d'emploi dédié je pense que ça
serait trop cloisonné je pense que c'est
pas ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse
aujourd'hui au contraire moi dans les
grandes lignes ce que je veux faire en
sorte c'est que on ferme pas les viviers
de recrutement et on enferme pas dans un
parcours de dire vous êtes recruté
secrétaire de mairie vous allez rester
secrétaire à toute votre vie mais qu'il
faut au contraire qu'on puisse permettre
une fluidité des parcours des agents par
exemple dans des espaces françaises qui
peuvent avoir des profils intéressants
vice versa devenir DGS par la suite dans
un cadre évolutif je crois en revanche à
une forme de notion d'affectation
fonctionnelle de dire au fond d'exercer
ce métier là ça recouvre une technicité
un engagement particulier et c'est comme
ça qu'on doit pouvoir peut-être attraper
d'une certaine façon la filière
professionnelle des des secrétaires de
de mairie et y compris sur les
possibilités de promotion on y reviendra
dans dans les débats et sur les propos
les possibilités de valorisation dans la
rémunération moi je suis très favorable
à ce que vous évoquez mais il faut voir
comment le traduire exactement et je
rentre pas dans le débat on le rat je
crois en séance mais le fait qu'exercer
ce métier de secrétaire de mairie puisse
donner lieu à une forme d'accélérateur
de grille d'ancienneté d'accélérateur de
carrière parce que un temps donné dans
votre carrière vous exercez cette
fonction-là et qu'ensuite on puisse
cranter son niveau de rémunération et
c'est je crois une des vertus de ce qui
a été travaillé dans la proposition de
loi mais est-ce que c'est la bonne
est-ce que ça traduit de la bonne façon
je crois qu'on aura le débat mais en
tout cas dans la philosophie de dire il
y a une forme d'affectation
fonctionnelle qui permet une évolution
et qui permet un accès à temps de
carrière je crois que c'est en tout cas
cette idée là qu'on doit essayer de
creuser ensemble
sur sur le les interactions et la
question des référents je pense qu'elle
est très fondamentale dans le lien entre
la territoriale et l'État déconcentré
deux points sur sur ce sujet là je crois
qu'on doit renforcer l'état des
concentré voilà pardon de l'évidence
peut-être mais c'est vrai que la
fonction publique d'État des concentrée
a rendu beaucoup d'emplois ces 20
dernières années
20 à 30 000 dans les 30 dernières années
l'état déconcentré aujourd'hui au niveau
départemental c'est 50000 agents je mets
de côté les uniformes et les professeurs
en disant ça mais l'administration on va
dire c'est à dire
une puissance de feu qui est peut-être
moins important que ce qu'elle était
avant et qui met en difficulté parfois y
compris les partenaires de l'état des
concentrés qui sont
qui sont les territoires donc moi je
crois à une politique de déconcentration
qui doit être double ça veut dire
dans un cadre de stabilité d'emploi moi
j'ai un ministre de la Fonction publique
dont le mandat repose pas sur des
suppressions de poste voilà on a y
compris majorité présidentielle bouger
là-dessus programme de 2017 du candidat
Macron n'est pas le programme de 2022 du
président réélu Emmanuel Macron
stabilité d'emplois mais en revanche
essayer de par la performance de dégager
des marges de manœuvre pour déconcentrer
des postes et les renvoyer en
administration des concentrés on a un
programme de déconcentration de 2600
postes d'ici 2026
pour renvoyer des administrations
centrales en territoire donner des
marges de manœuvre au préfet de région
avec les plateformes régionales RH je
les réunirai demain matin pour faire un
point avec elle pour faire appliquer la
règle des 3% de marge de manœuvre
moduler pas de Big Bang de
l'administration territoriale mais plus
de moyens pour réussir voilà si je
devais résumer en un mot je crois que ce
sont les enjeux c'est à dire
renforcement des moyens des pflh qui
sont je crois et qui doivent jouer un
rôle d'animateur à l'échelle de la
bassin de vie dans une logique plus
mutualisée de bassin d'emploi se
développe des comités de locaux de
l'emploi public auquel je crois
certaines régions et certains bassins de
vie sont en train de les développer très
fortement et on doit se donner les
moyens d'animer ces comités locaux de de
l'emploi public ça doit être très
important ça c'est le premier axe puis
le deuxième axe c'est notre capacité
d'animation des services publics
territorial si je puis dire et là je
crois qu'il y a une très bonne piste
pour les référents des secrétaires
admirés au sein des des administration
nous avons réuni le gouvernement il y a
deux semaines autour de la première
ministre sur l'enjeu des services
publics beaucoup de décisions étaient
prises dont deux qui me semblent
particulièrement intéressantes à cette à
ce titre là la première c'est de nommer
dans chacune des préfectures
départementales un sous-préfet en charge
de l'accès de la qualité des services
publics d'avoir un sous-préfect qui soit
entièrement dédié à cette question-là et
qui pense maintenant midi et soir
deuxième décision complémentaire qui est
de renforcer le réseau des animateurs de
notre réseau France service c'est un
autre débat on l'aura d'autres temps
peut-être mais on doit mieux mutualiser
les réseaux de service public qui doit
pas y avoir France service d'un côté le
reste du monde de l'autre voilà pour le
dé rapidement et se développe
aujourd'hui des postes d'animateurs de
ce réseau là qui sont souvent des
reportés par les collectivités souvent
des départements qui jouent et qui sont
financés
à un demi à hauteur d'un demi-etp par
l'État et nous avons pris la décision de
doubler ce financement et donc de
pouvoir financer un et TP dans chacun
des départements qui soient entièrement
dédiés à l'animation de ce réseau-là et
je pense que c'est profils là à mon avis
serait justement choisi pour être le
correspondant et le contact des
secrétaires de mairie parce
qu'aujourd'hui les deux réseaux de
guichets secrétaire de mairie si je puis
dire être guichet franc service
se mutualise pas forcément assez les les
informations ce qu'on sait faire comment
on peut se renvoyer les usagers etc et
je crois qu'on a intérêt à mener ce
travail en meute je peux dire pour pour
mieux répondre et renforcer donc il y a
là pour moi une piste intéressante sur
ces référencés là sur la question pardon
je veux pas le l'éviter des NBI moi je
suis prêt à ce qu'on se pose la question
je pense que elle doit être prise dans
le cadre du débat global qu'on aura sur
les accélérateurs de carrière des
secrétaires de de mairie leur
possibilité d'évolution de C pour 74%
d'entre elles en B et qui sont là des
bons accélérateurs de carrière d'une
certaine façon pour les secrétaires je
note que parfois les NBI ne sont pas
appliquées alors même que c'était la loi
puisque c'était une décision qui devait
concerner l'ensemble des secrétaires de
mairie et donc on a quand même un sujet
d'abord d'effectivité de l'application
de ces 15 points de NBI qui ont été
décédés dans le précédent qu'un Kena si
on veut avancer sur sur ces questions là
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour
ces
pour ces réponses et les intentions
alors nous nous pratiquons ici
envers certaines structures de l'État ce
qu'on appelle une filature exigeante et
bienveillante l'anxiété et notre
première exemple et nous ne manquerons
pas de chiffres avec intérêt
l'effectivité des choses parce que vous
l'avez dit moi je crois qu'il y a pas
simplement une question de moyens il y a
une question d'articulation et de
coordination de fluidité vous l'avez dit
entre les Français services et services
municipaux et puis justement sur ce que
vous ai dit ce que les collègues mettent
en évidence c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui le
statut n'est pas un élément
d'attractivité il paraît pour des jeunes
d'un élément un peu d'emprisonnement et
en tout cas incompatible avec la liberté
c'est exactement ce que l'on vit dans le
secteur privé ou aujourd'hui
des jeunes y compris des jeunes adultes
refusent des CDI préfère décéder
intérim parce qu'il garde la possibilité
d'aller retour dans des périodes de
travail et en tout cas de pouvoir
préserver leur liberté leurs envies je
serai pas plus longue je passe la parole
on peut faire deux choses si vous voulez
monsieur mini Antoine le faire et si le
Robert puis
Christine lavard des Nadine bellerault
Antoine merci madame la Présidente et
merci monsieur le ministre pour vos
propos extrêmement positifs et
volontariste et nous vous rejoignons sur
la nécessaire fluidité des parcours moi
j'aurais trois remarques tout d'abord
question vous l'avez évoqué assez
brièvement
notamment par rapport à la situation du
handicap et moi je je reste d'ailleurs
on avait j'avais fait un rapport sur la
formation dans la fonction publique au
sein de la délégation on avait évoqué la
mise en valeur davantage de la
l'apprentissage je trouve que c'est
notamment l'avait examiné ce qui se
passe en Allemagne ou en Autriche
particulièrement
ou sur les fonctions administratives
c'est beaucoup plus développé alors nous
on connaît le développement de
l'apprentissage dans les dans les
métiers
notamment dans les centres technique
municipaux ça se développe et à mon avis
c'est largement perfectible et je pense
que ça reste aussi une voie d'accès pour
des jeunes justement de découvrir les
métiers qui sont diverses de la fonction
publique territoriale
et puis pour revenir justement sur le
thème qui avait évoqué Cédric Vial sur
pesant même le finalement le statut de
la fonction de lui-même je voudrais
évoquer alors c'est bien que c'est
toujours un
je ne sais pas si c'est un gros mot là
mais lorsqu'on évoque les contractuels
je pense que si on veut retrouver de
l'attractivité il faut aussi permettre
une certaine fluidité dans ce dans ce
type d'accroche et j'en veux pour preuve
en tant que rapporteur de la mission
justice les propositions du garde des
sceaux notamment au niveau de la
pénitentiaire où on veut justement
permettre de recruter des contractuels
tout à l'heure justement la présidente
évoquée parce que on dit c'est un
concours où on se sent emprisonné pour
le coup un jeune il se dit j'ai pas
envie de signer un concours et toute ma
vie je serai gardien de prison et donc
ça fait peur finalement par contre on a
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont dans les
métiers de sécurité et parfois
parce que il y a un centre pénitentiaire
à proximité le fait d'être pouvoir
découvrir ce métier finalement de se
dire finalement il y a plus de diversité
de métiers de choses intéressantes dans
ce métier que de d'être le chef des
vigiles d'un centre commercial et
finalement
surtout que dans la fonction publique
enfin dans la pénitentiaire pardon on
développe vraiment cette attractivité je
crois qu'il y a il y a vraiment ce sujet
cette question qu'il faut poser et si ça
vaut pour la pédicure je pense que ça
vaut aussi pour d'autres
métiers et puis sur ce
sur ce sujet je voudrais simplement oui
alors là c'est anecdotique mais lorsque
vous évoquiez justement le meilleur
prise en compte des parcours moi il y
avait quelque chose en tant que mère qui
qui me gênait toujours c'est que lorsque
des on avait la remise de médaille
communale départementale régionale qui
est un peu l'équivalent de notre
médaille du travail dans la fonction
publique territoriale et bien certains
se étaient pénalisés puisqu'il avait eu
un parcours un peu dans le dans le dans
le privé c'était pas comptabilisé or la
médaille du travail c'est comme si on
leur avait amputé une partie de leur vie
professionnelle c'est un peu bon ça
faudrait quand même parce que on est
dans le symbole mais c'est important et
puis dernier
remarque on a plusieurs fois parler des
sous-prés référents aux correspondants
attention quand même
nos sous-préfet sont quand même déjà
très très surchargés de moins en moins
d'effectif dans les préfectures
sous-préfecture si on leur donne des
missions trop vastes qui pourront pas
les mener donc l'idée l'idée est bonne
mais il faut voir les activités merci
Antoine tu as raison sur
les sous-préfectures mais je pense qu'on
a on a des idées qu'on pourra vous
proposer à un moment beaucoup plus tard
puisque on ne fait pas que solliciter
des idées demander aux contribuer à
porter des solutions souvent pertinent
monsieur mille et Sylvie
merci merci madame la Présidente et
merci à Monsieur le Ministre et à nos
collègues je partage bien évidemment
beaucoup des constats et des réflexions
que que vous avez je voudrais
pas obligatoirement de questions
précises mais faire part de réflexions
notamment sur la question de l'attirance
et l'attractivité je suis frappée
étant à la commission culture et
éducation du Sénat de la façon dont on
parle de la fonction publique question
d'orientation des jeunes il y a un sujet
d'image il y a un sujet qu'il faut
absolument
traiter pour convenir que oui la
fonction publique territoriale ou d'état
peut être innovante peut être et ça
c'est pas les discours que l'on entend
il y a un vrai une vraie question
d'orientation donc ça c'est attiré après
fidéliser je crois que il y a vraiment
des processus à mettre en place moi je
vois à Rennes lorsque la plateforme de
mobilité interne a été mise en place
pour accompagner au changement de métier
une promesse pour les agents c'est à
dire le fait de ne pas rester tout le
temps dans le même métier et de pouvoir
un moment évoluer ou même tout
simplement changer et j'ai observé le
nombre de candidats et j'ai été frappé
vraiment par
l'attirance en tout cas de de telles
plateforme donc la compagnement au
changement je trouve que c'est mais vous
en avez parlé en termes de management et
deuxième réflexion j'ai été aussi
frappée je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez je crois que c'était il y a
deux ans les étudiants de Sciences Po
Paris il y avait un gros pariais qui
avait fait des propositions sur le
service public et on voyait bien que
derrière pour rendre attirant bien sûr
la question de du service public de
toute façon générale pas
collectivité ou autre et il voulait le
rendre inspirant c'est-à-dire permettre
en tout cas que finalement les valeurs
je parle de valeur parce que on a tous
des jeunes adulte comme enfant et on
voit bien comment il parle du travail et
du rapport au travail aujourd'hui cette
notion de confiance de coopération de
management de Plus horizontal et moins
hiérarchiser de conditions de travail
moi j'ai mis en place un bureau d'étang
il y a très longtemps à Rennes pour
essayer de travailler sur les temps
justement de la ville et de voir comment
on pouvait concilier les temps de
service public et
j'avais travaillé sur les bibliothèques
donc après voilà ma loi bibliothèque a
permis de prendre en compte aussi les
conditions de de travail le dimanche sur
des temps atypiques je pense que c'est
des je vois pas beaucoup de
collectivités alors que cette question
de conciliation des temps à la fois des
agents mais aussi des temps de service
public et des citoyens me semblaient
extrêmement important tout ça fait
partie de de l'innovation et si on veut
faire entrer des jeunes dans le dans la
fonction publique
je pense j'ai pas parlé des personnes
âgées je pense enfin seniors comme on
dit c'est un vrai sujet je vais pas
l'aborder mais d'autres enjeux mais en
tout cas sur la question des temps je
trouve que c'est important et puis tout
simplement cette question d'être utile
aux autres d'engagement ce sont des
valeurs c'est et ça ça peut les jeunes
aujourd'hui sont très sensibles à ces
assez valeurs là et pour terminer
moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec la 27e
Région allez à l'époque quand j'étais
vice-présidente à la région Bretagne
alors c'était une promesse assez
étonnante de la 27e Région vous la
connaissez et je trouve qu'on devrait
c'était en 2008 il y a plus 27e Région
c'était 26 + une mais c'était là qui
sont du numérique et de voir comment en
terme d'innovation publique de
transformation de nos politiques
publiques et même de processus des
transformations publiques du rapport aux
usagers du rapport numérique on pouvait
du coup derrière influer sur les
organisations et je trouve que on
devrait s'inspirer de cette 20e région
qui comment qui continue à fonctionner
pour un moment montrer aussi que Ben
cette fonction publique oui elle est
innovante même si sur la question du
numérique je dois vous avouer que je
reste encore assez dubitative bon je
suis commissaire de la CNIL je vois que
en termes de cyberattaque je vois en
termes de du de on va dire de je parle
de garde du corps numérique de de
processus de bon usage du numérique dans
nos organisations et du coup d'en faire
vraiment une valeur ça reste quand même
un sujet alors même que aujourd'hui la
numérisation de l'ensemble de de
beaucoup de d'éléments et quand même et
quand même très très important voilà mes
trois réflexions qui ne sont pas
obligatoirement des questions mais qui
voilà peut-être alimenter voilà nos
propos merci
je rappelle que ce sujet nous a beaucoup
préoccupé et qu'en corrélation ou encore
des Nations avec la délégation aux
entreprises qui a conduit un travail
remarquable sur cybersécurité nous avons
fait un rapport initiation sur la
cybersécurité dans les organisations et
nous avons vu comment il y a une prise
de conscience très importante comment il
y a un travail assez considérable qui
est mené soit l'échelle des intercos
aujourd'hui des avec l'aide de l'âge
gendarmerie pour considérer qu'il y a
dans nos collectivités dans la plus
petite commune dans le plus grand
hôpital il y a aujourd'hui une fonction
de cybersécurité qui n'a rien à voir
avec un système d'information et les
choses montant puissant c'est ça c'est
des nouveaux métiers extrêmement
remarquables de la fonction publique
d'État mais aussi territorial ou
hospitalière
monsieur le ministre après nous aurons
une deuxième série de qui tient avec
Christine l'avare des Nadine melrot
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci à vous
alors Monsieur sénateurs
à développer un tout petit peu sur
l'apprentissage en partant du handicap
d'ailleurs ce que je trouvais être à mon
avis
un bon point d'entrée je le disais tout
à l'heure l'apprentissage des personnes
en situation de handicap doit se
développer davantage
nous aurons d'ailleurs l'occasion de
rénover un décret au mois de juin et qui
sera publié au mois de juin sur la
titularisation des apprentis en
situation de handicap c'est existant
dans les textes c'est mal formulé
aujourd'hui c'est pas clair et c'est mal
appliqué
la loi de transformation vous avez été
rapporté
en situation
je me tournerai vers mon cabinet
extrêmement compétent
d'expérimentation pas en tout cas
toujours est-il que nous allons publier
au mois de juin décret pour le rentrer
dans le dur et je parle sous contrôle de
la chambre
mais pour clarifier justement les
modalités et faire en sorte que ce qui
fait consensus aujourd'hui puisse être
appliqué et élargi c'était l'intention
que que je développais tout à l'heure de
faire en sorte que il faudra être
attentif dans une filature bienveillante
et exigeante
sur les modalités d'application mais
quand il y a une volonté partagée d'un
employeur qui a pu éprouver des
compétences d'un jeune apprenti parfois
pendant 18 mois ou deux ans ou 24 mois
qu'on puisse titulariser les les
apprentis et donc on doit encore le
renforcer
il y aura aujourd'hui 30 000 apprentis
dans la fonction publique on va arriver
à 12000 apprentis dans la fonction
publique territoriale on a des enjeux de
financement bien connus et qui sont en
discussion aussi avec le CNFPT pour
pouvoir continuer à financer moi j'ai
maintenu l'engagement des moyens de mon
ministère pendant trois années pour se
donner vraiment la visibilité par
rapport aux engagements en convention du
CNFPT il y a des enjeux de financement
il y a des enjeux aussi de cadres
d'exercices de l'apprentissage on a pris
la décision de sortir des plafonds
d'emploi ça concerne la ministères les
apprentis c'est une décision assez
concrètes pour aider faciliter pour
lever les freins on a pris la décision
de et c'est effectivement de numériser
les contrats d'apprentissage on est même
là on avance de face sur le privé sur
ces questions là bref de faire en sorte
qu'on puisse tout faire pour continuer
cette cette révolution de
l'apprentissage en fonction publique et
qui me semble un des bons leviers un
seul mais un des bons leviers pour pour
répondre à nos enjeux vous avez
mentionné la question des contractuels
en prenant un exemple qui me semble
particulièrement pertin c'est le travail
qui a été mené avec le garder ça sur la
filière des métiers de la sécurité si je
peux dire je le dis à descendre comme ça
parce que moi je crois qu'on doit
davantage raisonner par filière métier
par univers professionnel de certaines
façons et comme ça on va pouvoir
développer des fluidités un peu moins
avec une différenciation qui ne serait
que statutaire mais un peu plus sur
vraiment le contenu du métier et le
travail qu'on a mené avec le garde sur
la filière des surveillants
pénitentiaires me semble être une bonne
illustration à mon sens de ce qu'il
faudrait élargir est-ce que je
comprenais d'élargir dans une réforme
autour de l'accès des parcours et de la
rémunération qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a
considéré qu'il fallait surtout pas
fermer les viviers de recrutement
aujourd'hui il y a 25% des surveillants
pénitentiaires qui sont embauchés qui
ont pas le bac et donc il y avait une
revendication ancienne des organisations
syndicales qui étaient déjà passées de
catégorie ça catégorie B les
surveillants pénitentiaires parfois avec
un petit peu de course à l'échalote
entre la filière police et la filière
pénitentiaire mais on a considéré de se
dire si on fait ça et on que ça dans ce
cas là catégorie B on peut pas rentrer
catégorie Besson n'a pas le bac ça doit
correspondre à un niveau de de formation
et donc ça peut être au contraire une
fausse bonne idée une certaine façon à
fermer les vives recrutement donc la
décision a été prise de dire on va
permettre à un recrutement au contrat en
début de carrière des surveillants
pénitentiaire ensuite on va lever le
niveau d'exigence et de mission qui
seront confiées à la filière
pénitentiaire notamment sur les enjeux
de réhabilitation de réinsertion et
parce que le niveau de mission confiée
donc le niveau de compétence attendu et
en élévation à ce moment là ça justifie
le passage à la catégorie B et donc je
pense qu'on a là un continuum et c'est
comme ça qu'il faut raisonner et c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que le garde a
obtenu des arbitrages pour pouvoir
donner suite à une revendication
historique et j'étais assez coté à Agen
au moment où il annoncé avec un retour
assez favorable des organisations
syndicales sur sur cette question là
vous vous avez mentionné oui pardon la
question du passage dans le privé
je connaissais pas le point pour les
médailles du travail il est symbolique
mais il est très représentatif je suis
d'accord avec vous
au fond d'une philosophie qui
considérait que un moment donné quitter
la fonction publique pour la rejoindre
ensuite ça serait mal il faut se le dire
sans tabou moi je j'aurais un discours
complètement contre toi si je voulais
favoriser plutôt la fluidité et
c'est exactement de l'anti fluidité si
un moment donné ben oui on peut aller
voir un moment donné dans le privé
acquérir parfois des compétences des
modes de travail des différemment et
venir réenrichir la fonction publique et
je le dis au passage pardon pour cette
taquinerie mais attention parfois à ce
qu'on fait avec plein de bonnes
intentions on a eu le débat sur les
cabinets de conseil externalisation en
se disant ben il faut réinternaliser des
compétences c'est le premier à le dire
mais parfois on se met des règles du jeu
en matière de déontologie en disant
attention vous venez dans la fonction
publique je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui dans le monde du conseil
c'est quand même pas facile d'être
embauché dans la fonction publique par
exemple à la direction intervient la
transformation publique et d'avoir
l'idée peut-être un jour de repartir
dans le privé les règles parfois si on
va au bout du geste tel qu'elles sont
définies elles rendent absolument
impossible à un aller-retour
d'entreprise et privé et je le dis parce
qu'il y a des articles de presse sur des
gens qui ont donné du temps parfois en
étant fonctionnaire parfois en étant
ministre on a l'impression que de partir
dans le privé c'est un pantouflage
affreux horrible quelle idée
insupportable que des gens puissent
retourner en privé je pense qu'on a une
responsabilité collective de temps en
temps tordre un peu le coup à des
facilités quasi quasi populiste je veux
d'abord vous remercier madame la
sénatrice Sylvie Robert pour les
remarques que vous avez partagées je les
partage absolument toutes vous avez dit
quelque chose qui me semble essentiel
c'est d'abord comment on parle de la
fonction publique et je pense que ça
démarre par là
je crois qu'on collectivement on manque
pas de lucidité sur les difficultés
aujourd'hui on se dit les choses on
partage les chiffres elles sont réelles
mais arrêtons un peu parfois avec le
fonctionnaire bashing avec le fonction
publique bashing je vous dis ça vous
n'avez pas les les porteurs mais quand
dans le débat public à chaque fois qu'on
parle de fonctionnaires c'est pour
mettre un chiffre à côté c'est combien
on va en supprimer je crois qu'au fond
on fait pas du bien et pendant des
décennies on n'a pas tout le temps fait
du bien au débat public sur sur cette
question là et donc moi je veux qu'on se
dise quels sont nos difficultés mais
aussi tout ce qui se passe d'absolument
formidable dans la fonction publique et
aujourd'hui parfois on est en avance de
phase et vous avez mentionné les
laboratoires d'innovation territoriales
qui en font la suite des initiatives que
vous aviez déjà prises sur la 27ème
région non seulement je les connais mais
j'ai le bonheur à l'occasion de
d'échanger à l'Iran Nantes avec la
vingtième région le boulot qui est fait
maintenant dans les laboratoires
d'initiative territoriales qu'on est en
train de mieux fédérer pour essayer
justement à partir toutes les
formidables innovations territoriales
qui sont parfois mais vraiment en avance
de phase par rapport aux prévues on doit
on n'a pas à rougir tout le temps de ce
qui se passe dans la fonction publique
de sa capacité d'innovation justement on
a un enjeu de passage à l'échelle bien
souvent et de partir de ce qui se passe
de bien sur le terrain et d'essayer de
lui donner des moyens pour passer à
l'échelle c'est ce qu'on fait d'ailleurs
avec le fond transformation de l'action
publique c'est parfois dans les débats
budgétaires qu'on peut avoir moi j'ai
insisté et obtenu des arbitrages pour
qu'on maintienne un fond de
transformation de l'action publique 330
millions d'euros sur les trois
prochaines années avec une nouvelle
orientation qui est d'être mieux capable
de financer des initiatives
déconcentrées et parfois partenariale
entre l'état des concentré et les
collectivités qui est une bonne porte
d'entrée donc on a créé un guichet dédié
aux initiatives des concentrées qui est
faite exactement pour développer ce que
vous avez dit là c'est ce qui peut
naître dans des laboratoires
d'initiatives territoriales et qui
peuvent être portés ensuite en
partenariat avec une préfecture de
région par exemple un secrétaire général
d'une préfecture de région pour essayer
de changer des selles vagin mais c'est
c'est pour ça que je le dis parce que ce
sont des des moyens intéressants et qui
sont parfois porteurs de d'initiatives
qui qui mérite d'être d'être travaillé
je reviens pas sur le rôle des
plateformes territoriales on l'a dit
tous les deux il me semble que c'est
très important et au fond
les défis à relever les transformations
qui sont en cours moi je crois que ça
doit être un axe de communication très
fort pour la fonction publique on a
quand même vécu avec le covid quelque
chose qui est exceptionnel à la fois de
son caractère terrible pour ces œufs qui
ont laissé leur vie mais moi ce qui me
frappe c'est de voir le nombre
d'interlocuteurs fonctionnaire qui
viennent me voir et qui me disent j'ai
quasiment la nostalgie de ce qu'on a su
faire à ce moment-là
pendant le covid parce que ça va mal
démarré notre histoire faut pas se
cacher les choses mais à la fin on a su
travailler complètement différemment à
un moment donné parce qu'on a piloté par
des objectifs clairs de terrain on
devait sortir du merdier au fond ça fait
des énergies là on a vraiment des
cloisonnées on n'a pas considéré en
chapelle etc on a des cloisonné dans la
fonction publique d'État mais on a des
cloisonné aussi dans les versants de la
fonction publique on a raccourci les
chaînes hiérarchiques on a réhabilité ce
qui me semble extrêmement important je
parlais de management tout à l'heure une
forme de droit à l'erreur pour les
agents voilà on a créé le droit à
l'erreur pour les usagers il faut qu'on
puisse développer le droit à l'erreur
pour les agences c'est-à-dire la
capacité d'initiative de dire faites un
peu déroger vraiment réuni il y a
quelques jours les cadres de l'État
autour de la première ministre et elle a
passé ce message on ne peut plus clair
au préfet vous avez des capacités de
dérogation par la loi et ce que nous en
a donné encore des supplémentaires elles
sont parfois sous-utilisées et et donc
faites-nous remonter des choses c'est un
patron qui dit mais à un moment donné
moi j'en ai une très bonne on impose au
CHU de démontrer tous les j'ai oublié la
fréquence tous les 5 ans je crois que ce
CHU pratique encore la chirurgie un CHU
ça pratique des actes de chirurgie
d'évidence on a créé des droits à vie
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap faisons la démonstration qu'il
y a pas de la paperasse administrative à
faire donc ça je crois que c'est ce
qu'on doit réembarquer aujourd'hui on
doit le faire d'autant plus que on a une
sorte d'alignement de planètes pour
pouvoir faire ça le Conseil d'État vous
savez chaque année un cycle d'étude
particulière et a décidé cette année de
consacrer son cycle d'études à toutes
les dérogations qui ont été en cours
pendant le covid qui au fond nous ont
pas fait faire moins bien et qu'on doit
garder on a une occasion quand même de
simplification normative assez
historique là-dessus bah si la plus
haute juridiction administrative du pays
est capable de mener cette réflexion là
et de dire au fond qu'est-ce qu'on
embarque avec nous c'est à dire que
collectivement il faut qu'on soit
capable de faire ça et je conclus
là-dessus mais notamment parce que on a
un moment où je trouve
que on parle pas des langues étrangères
quel que soit un peu les bords
politiques en ce moment et quand j'ai
réuni les parties prenantes de la
fonction publique il y a en fin d'année
dernière et on converge quand même
aujourd'hui assez sur le discours de
dire oui a besoin de réinvestir il y a
besoin de plus de puissance publique
notamment sur les territoires
laisser faire c'est plus une option
voilà l'air du New public management
elle est peut-être un peu derrière nous
quand on externalisait absolument tout
mais pour autant faire seul n'est pas
une option non plus c'est à dire l'idée
que la fonction publique dans son coin
puisse faire
sans imaginer des partenariats y compris
parfois avec le privé de mobiliser
l'énergie et de se considérer comme un
levier des grandes transitions moi je
crois que ça c'est une occasion en
termes de doctrine d'action publique de
redéfinir ce qu'on doit être et c'est
très engageant pour les jeunes
générations et je le dis d'un mot de
conclusion on a lancé une formation très
approfondie trois jours de formation sur
la transition écologique pour les cadres
de la fonction publique d'État qu'on est
en train de déployer avec le CNFPT avec
tous les acteurs de l'hospitalière sur
l'ensemble de la fonction publique là on
a un boulevard on a un bouloir pour
redonner du sens et de se dire mais au
fond il y a un enjeu qui dépasse tous
les autres qui est celui de la
planification écologique sur lequel on a
un rôle massif à jouer et je crois que
ça peut irriguer toute notre action y
compris on aura l'occasion d'en
rediscuter des sujets de rémunération
moi qui souhaite instaurer des plans
d'intéressement dans la fonction
publique pour récompenser la performance
collective je pense qu'il y aurait le
meilleur critères dans les plans
d'intéressement que celui de la réussite
de notre capacité de mobilisation sur la
transition écologique donc on a là je
crois à une super opportunité de sens et
qui doit pouvoir nous redonner la chance
d'être peut-être des employeurs les plus
attractifs du pays voilà moi je le pense
et je vous dis des signaux peut-être
fait parfois mais positif que je vois je
fais le tour de toutes les écoles en ce
moment celle du service public
évidemment mais pas que et je vois Alix
à Sciences Po dans des grandes écoles
beaucoup de cérémonies de diplômes ou
parfois les élèves mettent la toque par
terre en disant on veut du sens et des
signaux faibles sur l'idée de se dire
que le service public est en train de
retrouver de la vigueur c'était beaucoup
banquier conseil à la sortie de
Polytechnique il y a quelques années
c'est en train de redevenir et ça se
traduit dans les fêtes des choix des
corps un peu plus service public on n'a
jamais eu autant de candidats à l'infp
qui est venu remplacer Léna que depuis
la création de l'ENA ce sont les
chiffres il y a une semaine que je vous
donne là
c'est intéressant quand même dans un
moment un peu catastrophique où on se
dit on va mettre par terre toute
l'attractivité ben non je crois pas que
ce soit ça qu'on soit en train de faire
et donc je conclus mon propos par cette
note positive donc on a deux questions
moi je voudrais juste je disais qu'on
était vigilant quand vous rappelez que
madame la Première ministre a raison
elle rappelle au préfet qui sont des
pouvoirs dérogatoires je voudrais quand
même juste rappeler parce que nous
suivons ça très près à la délégation on
a des collègues qu'on fait un rapport
sur les services déconcentrés qu'un
préfet ne peut déroger avec l'accord de
son administration centrale donc je
pense qu'il faut aussi lâcher un peu de
lait autour du préfet notamment pour
mettre en place des proportionnalités de
règles parce que le pouvoir
réglementaire on n'arrive pas à déroger
parce que le temps que la question
arrive administration centrale on n'a
pas pu attendre et que je ne suis pas
sûr que l'administration centrale
s'intéresse forcément très rapidement à
toutes les questions de nature et de
dimensions qu'on fera pas ça enfin alors
Christine et Nadine pour terminer les
interpellations mais
si qui m'attendu une perche que j'avais
l'impression que j'allais être hors
sujet mais lui-même est venu apporter la
question des corps et notamment des
corps techniques et c'est un sujet qu'on
suit depuis assez longtemps au Sénat
avec ma collègue Catherine difolco et ça
aurait pu être l'occasion de vous
entendre sur
ce qui va leur advenir puisque c'est une
question qui n'a toujours pas été
tranchée depuis la création de l'infp
vous connaissez notre position qui est
vous avez toute la conservatrice mais
c'est de conserver ce qui existe
notamment pour garder une vraie filière
technique et alimenter demain le CRMA
enfin tous les voilà parce qu'on n'est
pas c'est pas la même chose de
construire un pont ou une route que
d'être juge dans un tribunal et de faire
du droit enfin bon ça c'est notre vision
je sais pas si vous la partagez mais on
sera intéressé par savoir ce qui va ce
qui va advenir et le deuxième sujet
aussi que vous avez finalement sur
lequel j'ai pas entendu grand chose ce
matin et comme j'ai encore rien entendu
hier sur cette question
c'est tous ces métiers de la fonction
publique qui sont indispensables aux
vivre ensemble qui sont mal payés par
rapport au secteur privé je vais vous
donner quelques exemples je pense aux
professionnels de la petite enfance
versus les assistantes maternelles à
domicile je pense aux policiers
municipaux versus les agents de sécurité
je pourrais faire comme ça à une liste
assez précise de personnes et la
rechauffe parle encore plus avec la
casquette d'une élue urbain dense ou
l'immobilier est extrêmement cher il est
impossible avec le niveau de
rémunération qui est offert de se loger
dans la zone on travaille donc dans ma
collectivité j'ai des personnes qui
travaillent en crèche à la police
municipale qui sont svp qui habitent à
100 km de leur lieu de travail je sais
pas si c'est acceptable nous on essaie
désespérément de trouver des solutions
pour pouvoir améliorer leur rémunération
de manière à ce qu'elle puisse être sur
place aujourd'hui on se heurte
dès qu'on a une idée en fait on regarde
ça va permis il y a eu des
jurisprudences chambre régionale des
comptes c'est pas possible donc enfin
aujourd'hui on ne sait plus quoi faire
et la conséquence directe c'est que on a
des centaines de berceaux gelées dans
les crèches donc on a du foncier qui est
vide ce qui est quand même une
aberration on a des familles qui peuvent
pas faire garder leurs enfants
uniquement parce qu'on a des postes
vacants donc je sais pas quelle solution
vous avez apporté j'ai compris que
Monsieur comble avait pas d'idée mais
vous en avez peut-être
alors toutes les questions ont été
posées sur le statut de la fonction
publique l'attractivité
économique financière statutaire et tout
le reste donc moi je juste un autre
éclairage c'est que plus
particulièrement sur les
un peu de mal depuis ce matin sur les
secrétaires de mairie et notamment les
secrétaires de mairie des communes
rurales juste un angle à avoir en tête
c'est que en 2026 nous avons
des élections municipales et nous savons
combien le binôme maire et secrétaire de
mairie est important et il est important
que d'ici là en effet aussi des signaux
à des secrétaires de mairie parce qu'on
sait combien aussi des mers peuvent
s'engager ou pas s'ils se sentent aussi
rassurés d'avoir des secrétaires de
mairie qui sont là qui peuvent les
accompagner et on voit tous venir des
élections avec des de moins en moins de
candidat de vocation à être élu parce
que
et les violences en témoignent à l'égard
des élus ça ne ça ne fait plus guerre en
vie à nos concitoyens et c'est aussi un
paramètre à prendre en compte parce que
il y a dans nos communes des binômes et
je pense que certaines personnes
pourraient hésiter en sachant que bien
ils auront pas ce soutien technique
auprès d'eux aussi cette personne qui
connaît la commune et voilà donc inciter
à des vocations peut-être de façon
collatérale aussi inciter des hommes et
des femmes à se lever pour continuer à
faire vivre notre République
et donc pas une question
qui appelle peut-être quelques
commentaires et qui pourront et je pense
seront injuste titre développé à
l'occasion des débats approchants sur
les secrétaires de mairie alors j'ai
plein d'idées madame la sénatrice
certaines coûte un peu d'argent mais
j'ai plein d'idées d'abord sur les corps
techniques
je vais essayer de le dire en quelques
mots il y a beaucoup de travail qui a
été mené ces derniers mois sur la
question et dont le travail était
finalisé par la délégué intermédiaire à
l'encadrement supérieur de l'État Émilie
Piet mené ce travail-là j'ai pas
d'obsession de la symétrie
entre ce qu'on a fait pour les
administrateurs de l'État est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire pour les ingénieurs de
l'État je pense qu'il y a des éléments
de communs qu'on doit ré embarquer dans
la réforme des corps techniques et il y
a des éléments des spécificités qu'il
faut assumer et qu'il faut au contraire
pouvoir valoriser les éléments de commun
qu'il faut réembarquer pour les grands
corps techniques l'Insee les ponts eau
et Chaussées les ingénieurs de
l'armement les mines évidemment
c'est d'avoir plus de capacité à offrir
des carrières
diversifiées avec une gestion de
carrière qui soit beaucoup plus
interministérielle qu'aujourd'hui dans
les corps techniques on a une gestion
qui est parfois un peu silotée les
armées gèrent les ingénieurs de
l'armement et puis on est que aux mais
les ponts et chaussées sont gérés de
façon assez silotée alors même et
justement c'est un peu l'objet des
échanges qu'on avait précédemment que
quand vous avez des compétences
techniques d'ingénierie sur la
transition écologique vous pourrez les
exercer un jour au ministère de
l'Agriculture demain à Bercy pour
l'industrie des carbonées après demain
dans une administration des concentrés
dans une Real et moi c'est ça que je
souhaite développer pensant justement
que notre enjeu maîtrise d'ouvrage
pardonnez-moi mais il est encore plus
important en termes de besoins de
rarement que l'enjeu stratégie qui
occupe beaucoup d'espace du débat public
selon ton manque c'est des ingénieurs on
a besoin je dirais comme ça parfois de
plus de barreur un peu moins de plus de
rameurs pardon un peu moins de barreur
sur le terrain donc on a besoin de
proposer des parcours des cloisonnés
donc tout ce qui est au fond convergence
statutaire de grille de rémunération etc
avec la même logique plutôt
d'harmonisation par le haut et
l'exigence ça je pense que ça doit faire
partie de ce qu'on doit pouvoir
embarquer et je souhaite le faire dans
ce quinquennat et d'aller vers une
harmonisation décorts techniques dans
une logique de gestion des ingénieurs de
l'État avec leur spécificité et quelles
sont ces spécificités d'abord le côté
extrêmement technique parfois leur
métier je partage complètement ce que ce
que vous avez dit parfois de pas jeter
avec le bébé avec l'eau du bain sur ce
qui marche il s'avère que ses corps
techniques ils font de la du pilotage de
carrière parfois de façon un peu
corporative il faut se le dire mais ils
le font pas si mal que ça je pense par
exemple donc j'ai pas envie de mettre à
bas un système qui parfois fonctionne
qui permet de faire la gestion de
l'emploi qui permet de faire des
entretiens etc
c'est ça qui faut qu'on oui dans la
grande largesse mais bon bref il faut
assumer ça et puis un jeu d'attractivité
qui est très fort parce que des élèves
qui sortent Deluxe par exemple ils
rejoignent pas tous la fonction publique
ce qui est une différence avec des
élèves qui ont choisi d'infp je le dis
en étant à l'aise sur l'attractivité
renforcée de lier une espèce donc ça ce
sont les spécificités ça doit nous
conduire à mettre en place un système
avec une gestion par pôle de compétences
davantage autour des métiers de
l'économétrie mettez de la data les
métiers d'ingénierie autour de la
transition écologique notamment et avec
cette gestion par Paul de compétence
qu'on pourrait confier à la dièse
justement elle s'est délégué
interministériel d'avoir une part de
convergence sans mélanger les
administrateurs de l'État et les
ingénieurs de l'État en gardant leur
spécificité et en même temps une
animation beaucoup plus transversale de
leur parcours de cadre donc c'est ça
qu'on est en train de construire c'est
le travail de l'année 2023 pour pouvoir
initier cette réforme des corps
techniques à l'année 2024 et je peux
vous dire qu'il y a un attendu
notamment sur l'aspect indiciaire
indemnitaire qui a été revu vous le
savez pour les administrateurs de l'état
où j'ai assumé une harmonisation par le
haut il y a pas de raison que ce soit
les ministres les plus riches qui soient
capables de proposer les rémunérations
les plus élevées mais qui va de pair
avec plus de variables pour le dire
ainsi que je pensais une bonne gestion
pour les plus haut cadres de l'État et
ce qui était déjà le cas par exemple
pour les préfets enterrement d'accord
est-ce que vous avez sur les métiers que
vous avez mentionnés il y a des
départements j'ai changé avec le
président du conseil départemental du 93
il me disait moi c'est plus de créer des
emplois c'est les pourvoirs et ils
mentionner les mêmes exemples que vous
les PMI oui emploi ouvert dans une PMI
un pourvu on n'est plus en capacité de
rendre le service donc je pense que
c'est le cœur du sujet qui en méthode
doit pour moi mener un travail sur les
transformations structurelles qu'on doit
faire on en a très très largement parlé
là et puis avoir quelques démonstrateurs
d'une certaine façon où on n'attend pas
la grande réforme pour pouvoir avancer
et échanger les lignes c'est pour
particulièrement j'ai de la pétanque au
débat qu'on va voir sur les secrétaires
de mairie je pense que c'en est
évidemment un bon on est en train de
mener un travail qui va trouver son
achèvement dans les toutes prochaines
semaines sur la police municipale sur la
revue de la régime indiciaire et
indemnitaire qui sera un sujet
intéressant et je pense qu'on pourra
avancer sur cette question-là c'est un
travail que que je conduis évidemment et
avec les piloté par Dominique Faure sur
cette cette question et donc on doit
pouvoir avancer avec des démonstrations
concrètes sur certains métiers je pense
à une charte d'engagement pour les ATSEM
pour reprendre et allonger un tout petit
peu la liste que vous avez initié mais
globalement je terminerai là-dessus il
faut éviter la mauvaise différenciation
et assumer parfois la bonne
différenciation et je pense que l'enjeu
territorial que vous avez évoqué il est
pour moi central il y a des territoires
où il y a des enjeux de vie chers qui
nous faut pouvoir davantage appréhender
et il faut se dire les choses nos
indemnités la cartographie d'unité de
résidence par exemple bah elle colle
plus forcément à la réalité des faits je
le dis voyais en regardant droite en
face un sujet et j'évoquais le fait que
les décisions qu'on pourrait prendre
peuvent coûter cher sur ces questions là
remettre complètement à plat vous vous
parlez vite en milliards d'euros sur sur
ces questions là mais je crois que c'est
des questions qu'on doit pouvoir
appréhender et notamment sur la question
du logement je partage complètement ce
que vous avez dit et donc je souhaite
qu'on puisse avancer sur l'enjeu du
logement au moins dans trois directions
que je donne là pour pas être trop long
un enjeu de gestion de l'offre et de
pilotage de l'offre où nous avançons là
encore avec des silos qui sont beaucoup
trop étroits vous avez des armées que
j'ai assez bien le logement de ces
fonctionnaires il y a une politique du
logement à l'intérieur il y a des
mystères qui ont zéro politique du
logement et aucune mutualisation avec
les autres versants et notamment le
versant territorial la politique du
logement donc je souhaite qu'on puisse
lancer dans les toutes prochaines
semaines au mois de juin un comité
interministériel du des fonctionnaires
on piloterait avec Gabriel Attal qui a
la tutelle sur la die avec Olivier Knin
le ministre du Logement et moi-même pour
avoir cette angle sur le logement des
fonctionnaires pour mettre en place une
offre beaucoup plus décide en embarquant
les collectivités territoriales dans la
capacité d'animation autour de l'offre
de logement deuxième axe on aura des
travaux à mener sur des beaux
spécifiques pour les fonctionnaires
aujourd'hui il y a des rigidités qui
rendent l'accès au logement social au
logement intermédiaire difficile pour
les fonctionnaires et donc s'il faut
faire bouger la loi sur ces questions là
je souhaite qu'on puisse faire bouger la
loi sur ces questions là on aura des
travaux à mener là-dessus puis le
troisième sujet c'est de fabriquer du
logement parce que on pourra animer tout
ce qu'on veut en terme de politique du
logement si l'offre n'est pas développée
et je pense à du logement intermédiaire
à ta réservé aux fonctionnaires en
réalité on animera avec un seul peu
d'offre qui sera beaucoup trop votre P3
et donc là dessus il y a des initiatives
qui peut être pris de là non plus il y a
pas de fatalité je vois ce qu'on est en
train de faire sur le versant
hospitalier avec notamment la RS pour
les soignants et la PHP on investit 80
millions d'euros dans des programmes de
façon contractuelle avec des opérateurs
qui sont prêts à s'engager avec nous
parfois en libérant du foncé il y a des
fonciers de l'État par exemple qui peut
être mis à disposition avec une
contractualisation on est en train de
rencontrer l'ensemble des acteurs du
logement pour voir dans les prochains
mois quels sont les offres qu'on
pourrait développer avec ensuite des
logiques de logement réservés à certains
fonctionnaires je pense aux soignants je
pense aux policiers je pense à
effectivement à des métiers de la petite
enfance qui nécessitent de pouvoir
travailler près de chez soi pour des
enjeux qui sont à la fois de qualité de
vie au travail de pouvoir d'achat comme
d'écologie sur des problématiques de de
déplacement donc c'est des sujets sur
lesquels je veux vraiment pas rester les
bras ballants parce que oui il y a des
idées pour pouvoir avancer pardon de ma
réponse a peu longue mais sujet vraiment
d'importance
merci Monsieur ministre pour cette
réponse extrêmement complète mais un
certain nombre de choses que vous avez
des enfin évoqué ne pourront jamais
trouver à s'appliquer dans des zones où
il n'y a plus de foncier ça c'est ma
première remarque ma deuxième remarque
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le logement
intermédiaire et autre ne rentre pas
dans le quota et sérieux donc vous
prenez bien une commune qui est prélevée
de 6 7 8 9 10 millions d'euros par an
elle va faire que du logement qui compte
dans SRU et donc bien évidemment jamais
ces gens qui travaillent ne seront
éligibles à rentrer dans un logement et
enfin ma dernière remarque je vous avais
parlé rémunération je pense qu'il y a un
moment aussi où enfin si on veut que ça
marche il faut aller plus loin et je
vais donner les policiers municipaux par
exemple aujourd'hui on ne peut pas leur
appliquer les règles qui s'appliquent
aux pompiers c'est à dire que nous
brigade de sapeurs on a des militaires
ils ont pas de temps de travail donc ils
font leur leurs astreintes sur trois
jours il loge dans la caserne sur un lit
superposé et ensuite ils vivent quatre
jours dans leur maison
enfin qui est à 150 km de Paris
aujourd'hui moi mes policiers municipaux
je peux pas leur appliquer ce régime
parce que ils sont dans le code du
travail de la fonction publique à 35
heures par semaine ou donc ça et
pourtant ils font entre guillemets le
quasi le même métier enfin métier qui se
ressemble et c'est pas donc voilà ça
c'est et ça c'est au-delà de juste
verser de l'argent c'est aussi trouver
des solutions quand de toute façon on ne
pourra pas faire de logement enfin venez
je vous invite à faire une petite visite
Boulogne vous verrez qu'il y a pas de
foncier donc
à part sous terre peut-être et encore il
y a la scène
non c'était une alerte monsieur le
ministre quand je vous ai entendu parler
de la réforme de certains concours et
notamment de supprimer la phase
admissibilité
regardez ce qui se passe avec le
concours des Atsems c'est exactement ce
qui a été fait il y a déjà une dizaine
d'années maintenant
catastrophique pourquoi parce que
finalement tout le monde peut voilà
passer le concours d'ATSEM c'est à dire
un entretien de 20 minutes
comment peut-on juger quelqu'un sur 20
minutes voilà c'est difficile et en
réalité si la personne répond bien aux
questions elle a bien préparé elle est
présente bien etc etc etc elle a une
bonne note c'est à dire elle va avoir 18
et 18 elle va pas passer le concours
pourquoi parce que il y a 300 candidats
il y a 50 postes donc il faut il va
falloir avoir
19,75 pourquoi pas 20 et impossible de
mettre 20 à quelqu'un ça veut dire qu'on
a fait des Cortes de frustré parce
qu'elles ont pensé passer un très bon
entretien et elles ont passé je dis elle
pardon je vais encore m'attirer des
foudres mais c'est parce que c'est
beaucoup féminin non non mais je me suis
attiré des fous sur les secrétaires de
mairie parce que j'ai dit elle un jour
j'ai un mail comme ça incendiaire j'ai
un mail comme ça incendiaire donc voilà
peu importe je veux dire ces agents là
ces personnes là ont pensé passer un
très bon entretien ils ont passé un très
bon entretien à 18 ils sont recalés au
concours parce que justement l'épreuve
d'admissibilité permettait quand même
sur ces trois sans candidats et bien
d'en écrémé un certain nombre et de ne
pas laisser que 150 par exemple pour le
deuxième entretien donc faites attention
à ça parce que ça part d'une bonne
intention mais une fine et c'est
catastrophique voilà
sans passion mais je vous remercie de
votre passion parce que je crois que
elle nous en a elle est à l'auteur de
votre engagement mais je voudrais pas
que nous achevions notre conversation en
tout cas monsieur
d'engagement ça je peux vous le garantir
et 10 secondes qui est vraiment plus en
méthode moi je me conserve même pas loin
d'être le mieux placé pour juger
concours par concours etc donc je crois
que la seule bonne réponse c'est une
réponse de méthode c'est partir de la
situation vraiment du terrain de de
niveau d'exigibilité des critères
d'adminiscité actuelle du nombre de
candidats existants par rapport au
nombre de postes etc et de le faire avec
les employeurs territoriaux et vraiment
d'avoir des groupes de travail là-dessus
et où je pense que c'est pas au ministre
de décider d'en haut même si je me sens
vraiment ministre des trois versions de
la fonction publique qu'elles doivent
être telle ou telle épreuve il faut
qu'on le construise ensemble mais
le micro 4ème ce que n'entend pas je
vais me permettre d'alerter la
conférence des employeurs territoriaux
parce que je pense que dans cette
conférence il y a des il y a des
personnes qui ont vécu la même chose que
moi ce que j'ai vécu quand j'ai fait
passer les concours d'ATSEM voilà et
très sincèrement on s'est dit mais
mauvaise idée quoi bon attention
mauvaise idée oui d'association
de l'expertise du Sénat parce que
Catherine défoulcaux comme les collègues
connaissent bien les sujets pour les
avoir vécu aussi de l'Intérieur donc la
conversation est à prolonger sur ce
sujet particulier sur les autres non
mais vraiment en tout cas moi je veux
vraiment voilà vous remercier de d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation de l'échange
je crois extrêmement franc mais très
qualitatif que nous avons eu nous avons
évoqué beaucoup de questions d'une
manière dans la complexité des questions
parce qu'on sait au que rien n'est
miraculeux que les choses sont
difficiles et que il y a de la
complexité que parfois l'enfer peut être
pavé de bonnes intentions il y a des
sujets il faut qu'on soit imaginatifs
pour pour y répondre et en tout cas
vraiment en mon nom personnel au nom du
collègue je vous remercie pour
l'engagement que l'on sent dans la
manière dont vous exprimez donc vous
faites bouger les choses et vous êtes au
coeur je crois de l'efficacité de
l'action publique telle que nous la
souhaitons tous et tels que nos
concitoyens en ont besoin et qui est le
levier de rétablissement de la confiance
et de la cohésion sociale donc merci
Monsieur minier au plaisir d'autres je
pense que vous allez aussi faire l'objet
d'une filature de notre part parce que
il faut qu'on mesure les avancées ça
nous paraît intéressant merci en tout
cas merci beaucoup